[음악]
안녕하세요 bsn 있니다 오늘은
대한민국 최고 건축가인 유현중 건축사
사무소에서 설계하고 bsn 케어가
관리하고 있는 트러스트 2를 소개해
보도록 하겠습니다 서초역에서 약 도보
2분 거리에 위치해 있습니다
2023년 9월 15일 날 중공을
맞춰 아주 따끈따끈한 빌딩입니다 대지
면적은
494m 약 150평 정도 되는데
연면적은
2,336 이로 706평 a 규모를
가지고 있습니다 지하 3층부터 지상
8층까지 있고 빌딩 높이는 35.9
m 약 아파트 12층 정도의 높이이고
제 2종 글린 생활 시설 건물입니다
일단이 프로젝트를 진행할 때
건축주께서 주변에이
서초동이정재
그 변호사 사무실 테 통으로 임대를
주면 좋겠다 이런 말씀을 하셨는데
변호사 사무실의 요즘의 특징이
개개인의 변호사들이 약간 독립된 개인
사업자 럼 모여 가지고 하는 거잖아요
그 하나하나의 셀일 유니들의 되게
중요했어요 여러 명의 변호사들이
소수의 비서들을 공통으로 쓰거든요
그러한 프로그램 운영상에 맞춰서
평면도를 짰고 옛날같이 한 큰 통으로
쓰는 오피 스면 문제가 안 되는데
각각에 세대가 쪼개지는 셀들을 갖게
되니까이 외기고 접할 수 있는
표면적이 늘어나야 되는 거예요
그래야지만이 각각의 방에서 다 창문을
열 수가 있으니까 길가 쪽이 아니고
안쪽으로는 디귿자 형태로 안으로 더
다 왔잖아요 외기 아고 접할 수 있는
표면적을 늘린 거죠 그리고 그 가각의
셀들이 로변 쪽으로는 다 발코니 모두
다 나 있거든요 변호사들이 업무하다가
개인적으로 나가서 바람 세다가 다시
들어왔다 할 수 있게끔 하려고 그게
가장 중요합니다 높이 제한과
용적률이란 제한이 있는데 그 안에서
범표 최대로 맞 추고 높이도 최대한
다 쓰고 용적률 써도 빼내야 되는
그러한 볼륨이 있는 거예요 그래서
중간에 빼내야 되는 용적률 부분을
복층의 공간으로 마치 라이브러리나
회의실 같은 걸로 쓰게 해서 이게
변호사 사무실도 회의를 해 많이 해야
되니까 왕님은 했을 때 높은 천정
고에서 약간 드라마틱하게 미어
보이게끔 할 수 있게끔 복층으로 만든
거고요 복층을 더 드라마틱하게 보여
주기 위해서 높이 있게 그 책꽂이를
만들어 놓으려고 한 거예요 그래서
저녁 시간에 불을 켜놓 면은 그 법률
책들이 쫙 2층부터 꼭대기층까지
이렇게 쭉 있는 그러한 채지가
놓여지게 되어서 법률 사무실의 그
아이덴티티를 보여 주려고 하는 거죠
안쪽으로 저희 평면도를 보면은 세
명의 변호사단 한 명 정도로 비서가
앉을 수 있게 돼 있거든요 그러니까
그 비서들이 그쪽에서는 창문을 열 수
있게끔 되어 있는 거죠 어 설계는
되게 재미나게 효율적으로 잘 했던 거
같고요 근데 이제 공사는 사실은 좀
어려웠던 거가 중간에 코로나 끝나고
나서 공사비가 오른 적이 있어요 한
1.5배 이상 그런 부분 때문
때문에이
건설사하자접수
관리 여러 분야에 대한 이해가
필요하면서 각 분야의 인력들과 수시로
긴밀하게 소통하고 협업해야 됩니다
bsn 케어 팀은 앞서 말씀드렸던
건물 운영 관리에 대한 모든 업무들을
건물주 대표님들을 대신해서 우리
본인의 건물처럼 성식 껏 운영하고
관리하는데 전력을 다하고 있습니다
대표적인 관리 건물로는 서초
교대역에서도 위분 거리에 위치한 멋진
신축 빌딩이 있는데요 본 건물은
유현중 교수님께서 설계를 해 주셨고
연면적이 700평의 달하는만큼 해야
할 일들이 많은데요 호방 통신 전기
배관 기계 등의 각종 시설에 대한
최소 세팅과 시공사로 로부터 인수
인기 받을 것도 굉장히 많고 전체적인
시설의 하자 체크와 보수 건물
운영하는데 필요한 외주 업체의 세팅도
있을 거고요 인접 대지 건물주들과
소통도 필요하고 임대를 맞추기 위해서
뇌부 시설에 대한 세팅도 기본적으로
진행하고 있는 업무들 있니다 또한
bsn 임대 팀과 협업해서 현재
입주사를 모집하고 있는 중입니다
bsn 케어 팀은 저희 대표님들의
소중한 자산을 책임집니다 그에 걸맞게
bsn 그룹의 축적된 노하우와
데이터베이스를 바탕으로 체계적이고
효율적으로 업무를 수행해서 최고의
건물 운영 관리를 도와드리고 있습니다
트러스트 1은 세련 특색 있는 공간을
만들기 위해서 디테일을 굉장히 신경
쓴 건물입니다 오늘이 영상이 마음에
드셨다면 구독과 좋아요 눌러 주세요
그럼 다음 영상에서
만나요